- Hot wings are amazingly,
amazing-est, everything amazing.
- [Voiceover] What is your
all time favorite food?
- Pizza.
- Pepperoni pizza.
- Hamburgers and french fries.
- My favorite food is pancakes.
- I love mac and cheese.
- It grows your body healthy and strong.
- Because the syrup is yummy
and it's kind of fluffy.
- It all just melts in your
mouth after you bite the crust.
- It tastes like bananas
mixed up in sauce.
- Oh my God.
(stammers)
- Woohoo!
- A pancake.
- (laughs) Yum.
- This thing is huge!
(giggles)
(chuckles)
- (chuckles) It's funny.
- This bowl's ginormous.
- Taller.
- It kind of looks too big.
- It's not gonna come out.
Okay, I'm gonna move it.
(giggles)
- Kind of big but it's really yummy.
- I don't know why but them being so big
really makes it seem more delicious.
- This is awesome.
- So good.
- They're really really yummy.
This is it, I'm just gonna eat this one.
I don't wanna eat too much.
- Thank you.
- [Voiceover] You're welcome.